[Music]
please
hit us up
[Music]
stay still
get out of here
[Music]
fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
before the god
this is about a king
and river is the match
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
oh take it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
i'm vengeance
and blue
and dead
all over
dick
i got you
[Music]
is a concept about which we know
frighteningly
it was the only way
but i never
meant for any of this to happen
[Music]
wonder
i knew someone later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your
help guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
[Music]
i'm sorry steven
i hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
is you
things just got out of hand
[Music]
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
his exploits
or legendary
what he has to teach you
may very well mean the difference
between life
and death
your reputation precedes you
have to admit i wasn't expecting an
invitation back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting two versus one he's gotta be
kidding
[Music]
smoke in the air
[Music]
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there were just hundreds
of snakes in this temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete
delete delete
listen loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub drinking
chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model
you do know you're not dash right dash
is a character i made up oh my god
oh crap
miss sage i enjoyed your book about the
lost city and i believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your seatbelt
loretta sage is missing i'm gonna rescue
her i just want her to think of me as
more than a cover model
dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you i'm certified cpr served by
crossfit
i have snacks after them
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now i'm
gonna help you out a little bit let's go
what are you doing don't do that
get out of there this is not a romance
novel jungles eat people like us what is
that get it off
i can feel them
suckers like a bird
we're so close i could actually find the
lost city
if i don't get to this island my friend
and her cover model are going to die i
am driving oh
the red sage getting you out of here why
are you so handsome my dad was a weather
man
hey oh she doesn't need saving in there
uh what are you doing in there
[Music]
there are places out there you can't
find on any map
they're not gone
they're just lost
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
everything in here why the map this path
ferdinand magellan took the sail around
the world you know your history
it's the biggest treasure that's never
been found 5 billion easy
[Music]
find him too
who the hell is this i'm a friend of
sully's tally doesn't have any friends i
should know him one of them
[Music]
you're a collector well i dabble i'm
double
my family has been looking for this
person for a very long time so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatened to
kill me don't touch your ear like that
you look like an idiot
you have no idea who you partnered with
i've been dreaming about this stuff
since i was a kid my brother sayon left
one final clue
[Music]
what
crap
exclusively in movie theaters
july 20th
1969.
it's one small step
[Music]
in school you were taught that apollo 11
lost contact with the world for two
minutes
[Music]
not true
they found something on that day
that they kept him for 50 years
and now
it's too late to stop
in breaking news the governor has just
ordered the mass evacuation of the
entire west coast
moving to higher ground it's the only
possible chance of surviving
stay away my brothers and sisters stay
awake
this planet
has suffered five extinctions
this
is going to be the sixth
are we dead
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry brother
sorry that i brought you into this i
just wanted things to be the way they
used to be
that's my brother will i could use some
help my wife needs to search me this is
real life how's that right you put your
life down on the line for this country
you leave your family your home how much
do you need 231.
how about more
32 million and i need an extra minute i
came to you for a loan look if i ever
got you anything that i couldn't get you
out of it's time for you to do something
for your family
we're just doing a trance from the back
i'll let you in in 20 minutes if i could
just get it done real quick because i'm
on the clock promise not to rob the
place
seriously because that would be bad for
my
job okay all right all right come on
okay
[Music]
let's go dude you are all gonna have the
greatest story to tell at dinner tonight
lock everything down
nothing gets out
[Music]
what do you want just gonna borrow it i
got a cop shot i gotta get him to the
hospital i'm gonna need you to help us
why don't you help us we're doing
hostages now
we're not crashing into this ambulance
we got a brother cop on board do you
have empty experience come back to the
eyes you're a soldier yeah
we are trying to save you
right don't you move
you think you're so tough with that gun
yo daddy relax
i gotta get back to my life for my son
does your wife know you're all banks
we're not the bad guys
we're just the guys trying to get home
we don't get to walk off into the sunset
danny everybody knows how dangerous you
are do you
you get your heroes out of here now
i'm gonna get you back home now brother
i'm gonna get everybody home
[Music]
you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
are strange
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of you
he wants to hunt
and consume blood
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
other half wants to control you hey dr
mike you and i should stay in touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your server
as a private contractor
you're possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
what's that
power up you said it was clear i said
the front was clear
um
front back right wrong
anyway shall we
[Music]
so what we got something rather nasty
has been stolen we have to stop that's
getting onto the open market
who's the buyer greg simmons two
billionaire armstealer
oh a lot very serious faces up here in
there you can't catch this fish with
conventional lures i'm sorry the lure
being daddy francesco
the movie star rick simmons favorite
movie sir and how do we get him
blackmail
who's to gear
very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you i'm your new
manager
there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law i actually love my
sister-in-law
it's that of you you made that coin
evident when marimba rhythms start to
play i need to be nervous
no reason to be nervous
they're all the killers
you're an actor act
okay
i'm ready
let's go to work will someone pinch me
please is that danny francesca what's
next for you i'm playing a mysterious
self-made billionaire
you just described me
shadow maybe do whatever i do whatever i
do whoever greg was buying from was
amongst you last night the ukraine
i can get inside the ukrainians
i hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
you recognize your awesome fortune that
is a sexy name cover's blown we're burnt
what do i do the emergency is going to
melt
you stop daddy francesco you stop
breaking
let
them
so you weren't seen by anyone
yes
that's yes you weren't seen by anyone
yes or yes you were seen by someone
yes
[Music]
remember that story that they told us
about in training
about george washington's first female
spy during the revolution they called
her agent 355
because they didn't want the world to
know her real name
but her legacy lives
[Music]
we're on top agents from around the
world
american
british
german colombian chinese
but now we have a common enemy
they can start world war three
from simple reach of their keyboard so
we need to join forces
it's like half the cia's most wanted
always such a tough guy
i'm not an agent i'm a therapist they
thought i would give you my secrets do
you have secrets
we put ourselves in danger so that
others are not
i'll handle the guns
are you in therapy i should be
you're the best in the world of what you
do you have cameras in your jewelry
comes in your earrings you bump i grab
the target is on the move you're not
going in there alone we go together
i have a family i cannot do this anymore
the bad guys are out there right now
you go home
you bring them with you
are you under control are you no
i've got four more agents out on the
street i counted six but thanks for the
tip
i like the new team we're the 355.
[Music]
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you names tails okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
[Music]
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adorable
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again want to get out of
here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spiderman grounded
[Music]
i mean
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wake up buddy it is one o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
i have an owner and the superman let me
just turn that out
i should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who is he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets
but they're stronger than you think the
mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i indestruct dog
great i'm the only one who didn't get
any superpowers
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
sorry you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day two
just which is crazy i didn't even know
that was a thing but it's like a dog
water fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy k92 what is a k-9
invade
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
[Music]
tell me something
you can go
anywhere you want right
any timeline
and the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the past
are you in
oh
now
behold
he's here
he's here
father is here the kingman lady the king
your fake is sick and you cannot escape
it
now i've missed you my son
one day this kingdom will be yours
thank you father my king
[Music]
father
remember
foreign
[Music]
i will save you mother
i will kill you
why would they stow away to such a
hellish place
to find what was stolen from me
and what is that
the kingdom
you must choose between kindness for
your game
or hate for your enemies
your strength breaks nice bones
[Applause]
i have the calling to break their
[Music]
and minds by night we will carry out my
pledge of vengeance
hmm
[Music]
she's out
so
[Applause]
you're a hard guy to get to really know
do you even want a family
i do want a family
[Music]
name's perry
i work for grace
he wants you this address
i get
[Music]
i know who you are i know your name of
course your reputation precedes you
work for me i'm done with that really
you're gonna be fun to have a route
440 grand in here
we're gonna make this exchange or i'm
just gonna
[Music]
excuse me boys
do you guys mind moving out of the way
maybe somewhere over there
do you want to grab yours i'll grab mine
where are you driving off to in the
middle of a tuesday right
you know not much
[Music]
you got away
you know what this guy really knows how
to handle himself
so that makes things a little harder
[Applause]
oh my god
let me get you out of here okay i'm sure
you will you're here to take me thank
you
i went out of here too
one shot
can you run
can you run no but i am going to hop
like hell
[Music]
i'm gonna get away from all this
violence
starting
now
yeah now's good
[Music]
[Music]
you